[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu adores la police on
appelle à la vigilance de chacun
cheveux poils des aisselles et du pubis
les excréments la peau un truc d'odeurs
ce sont des trophées une seconde
monsieur le procureur venez voir ça on
reprend en étant dans la zone de
recherche
je veux tous les chiens disponible sur
le coup nous avons à faire un maître ils
ont parlé de l'emploi et de la faune que
pour le recherche activement
c'est peut-être un des types avec
quelques couches et elle était très très
lié à romane seliger et aux autres du
pensionnat vous allez faire leur truc
là-bas pour leur club secret leur club
secret des odeurs si on a essayé de
capturer les odeurs on trouve des
glandes aurifères dans les tissus
profonds des aisselles et des parties
génitales en supposant qu'on extrait ces
glandes
il serait possible d'obtenir un parfum
bien plus puissant qui commune et
meurtre pour vous
je les suspects tous même les nazes et
les gars c'est toi qui es tu et katarina
regarde moi
le mieux ce serait qu'on dise tout
un kit de la paix
reconnaissant
c'est l'histoire de grenouille un homme
qui a créé un parfum à partir du corps
des femmes qu'ils tuaient ans
enfin qui rendait tout le monde amoureux
celui qui le portait
de quoi avez-vous le plus peur
[Musique]
combien d'autres victimes vous comptez
faire